on va partir tout de suite en russie
mais à la frontière avec l'ukraine dans
la ville de tagant drogue c'est juste
après rostov sur le don s'efface un
précisément à l'ukraine rejoindre elena
volochine sur place lna faut-il
s'attendre dans les prochaines heures à
un mouvement de l'armée russe
je pense qu'il ne faut pas sous-estimer
la portée de ce discours parce qu'on l'a
entendu sur le ton et sur la forme pour
une fois on entendu vladimir poutine
exprimer le fond de sa pensée il a dit
il estime que l'ukraine n'existe pas en
tant qu'etat que sa création finalement
c'était un accident lié à la chute de
l'union soviétique
il a aussi dit que les sanctions
occidentales ne lui faisait pas peur que
de toute façon l'occident allait adopter
des sanctions contre la russie quoi
qu'elle fasse elle ne serait ce que
parce qu'elle augmente son potentiel
militaire dont vladimir poutine a
clairement dit qu'il n'avait pas peur de
l'occident d'ailleurs il a changé les
termes il ne parle plus comme il le fait
d'habitude deux partenaires occidentaux
mes deux collègues et n'oublions pas
qu'il a fini son discours par un
ultimatum en disant au gouvernement de
kiev désormais comme vous le disiez à
l'instant au plateau désormais plus une
seule goutte de son sinon vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir et moi qui
observent
la russie de vladimir poutine depuis dix
ans en étant en correspondance à moscou
c'est à dire la moitié du terrain
présidentielle je peux vous dire que ce
discours était véritablement un discours
sans précédent et que vladimir poutine
moi en tout cas à mon niveau me semble
absolument déterminés à aller jusqu'au
bout de ses revendications
un discours que vous avez senti dont
martial a on peut le dire et l'ena
elle extrêmement déterminé et encore une
fois on entendait tout ces derniers
temps ces termes pas tous ces derniers
temps d'ailleurs seulement depuis le
début du conflit en 2014 c'est terme de
génocide de nazis et c'est ça c'est
quelque chose qui revenait
régulièrement
on simplement entendu un cours
d'histoire de la part de vladimir
poutine ce qu'ils observent de près son
régime et toutes ces situations autour
de l'ukraine de l'est on a vraiment plu
et vu le fond finalement encore une fois
de sa pensée il exprime très très
rarement autant vis-à-vis de l'ukraine
que vis-à-vis des occidentaux vladimir
poutine là où certains considèrent qu'il
bluffe en réalité et ça des sources
proches de son entourage le confirmerait
c'est que il est réellement paranoïa
qu'il pense réellement que l'otan de
peut tirer des missiles sur la russie
est donc finalement la technique ici l
état d'esprit ici c'est faire la guerre
pour avoir la paix c'est assez orwélien
comme vision à mais cela existe dans son
esprit en tout cas de tous que tout ce
que peuvent en dire les analystes est
donc encore une fois ce discours c'est
quelque chose
qui peut sonner comme un avertissement
ou la prochaine fois
le blé avec son regard et son ton la
prochaine fois nous dira je vous avais
prévenu cette fois c'est fini en tout
cas voilà ce qu'il a dit ce soir
vladimir poutine je vous propose dans
l'écouté à un bref extrait mercier l'ena
volochine